[Music]  April 88 and lost everything eras on the  balls of my ass scrambling we had a  dream go just had not yet you know still  you got a strike Camino Mike we got a  goal you believe you're sitting on the  largest gold fine to the deck you're  talking over thirty billion dollars feel  like talking anyways you know this son  of the [ __ ] Jerry controls more gold  many but on the goddamn planet possibly  exceptional Mister dillos this is an app  engine this is how it happens  we can help you get off the side of that  mountain before I can land this plane  just be open to strategic alliances you  Brian Knight the gold is mine I found it  these you are using  and marry you with these hands these are  very powerful people of our language  these people are killers  the only question is how did 17 billion  disappear overnight  no bows no Thea well you will see what I  see  and this money not our money oh mama I'm  in fear for my